[Music]
this is it
this is the first study it was chosen by
mr. shrimps he told me a number I looked
through my database through my studies
database and this is what I came to we
have 10 of them we're probably not going
to finish all of them I doubt we're
going to finish all of them maybe two or
three four at the most
most of them are quite difficult and
yeah let's uh let's start I think is
white to move if I'm not mistaken so
let's try to give it a shot
I think first we should start with
candidate moves obviously the most the
ones that pop into our eyes immediately
are which was yes
Knight c2 to give the night like this
right here that just gives the night
though right and then well yeah but root
G to and then okay I'm going
oops I'm going to play something like
Knight c4 even if I would give you my
knight even if I would play Bishop f5
rook takes b2 that's still a draw right
route versus Bishop is a theoretical
draw so I don't think that's what we're
striving for and our Knight is not under
attack so I don't see the reason why we
would play Knight suit
mm-hmm mm-hmm absolutely I think that's
the first thing we should start
calculating I mean it puts the king in
the center it kind of traps the night
attacks the bishop so you know we're
looking for forced moves of course
that's how we should always start our
calculation our selection mode right so
King before should be the first move now
black has a lot of options
Bishop a for Bishop a - well Bishop a -
can easily be refuted after obg - I
think that's safe to say the game is
over
Bishop C - Bishop c4 don't work
Night Moves doesn't make don't make a
lot of sense so I think we Bishop d5 is
one Bishop d1 is another one Bishop
eight - and Bishop a4 yeah do you guys
want to put them on the put King before
on the board or do you guys wanna try to
figure it out from the beginning usually
I whenever I do it whenever I do it at
home and I prepare myself for a
tournament I try to solve it from the
beginning and one thing I I force myself
to do whenever I sort of studies is keep
an organized thought process very very
organized and that's going to help you
tremendously with your own game with
your own calculation during the game so
let's not jump from one variation to the
other
let's finish one and then go to the next
one which one do you guys want to start
with 95 Bishop c6 I would say actually
Bishop c6 is losing because of what
King the seven yeah so if we go here
everything is first and we're going to
win the piece but I think instead of
Bishop c6 maybe I have to do something
like all the way to h1 or maybe just
attack maybe just attack it like this
let's see if we have something better
let's see if we have something a little
bit more forced so what he's saying rook
g6 King f7 group the six Bishop e6 and I
think my bishop is more or less safe at
what in what moment king f7 ruby six mmm
right right that makes much more sense
rugby six so let's see
all right I'm surviving
I don't think I'm gonna trade I'm not
sure you're threatening anything 96 king
is six-night here King here that should
be winning but it's not is it
kink somehow I'm surviving let's see if
we can find something easier I'm pretty
sure it should work as well but maybe it
doesn't and if it doesn't then were in
trouble I think there's some easier path
in this position yes our June night King
the six tell me the whole variation
don't guess calculate that's why I'm
saying keep an organized thought thought
process there's actually a variation
that goes all the way until the end and
you just could easily see that it's
winning because he's losing all his
pieces by force
now raakhi 3 is actually the right move
rocky 3 is actually the right move just
calculate it till the end the line is as
follows
rook to e3 King the six-night to b5 King
c6 Knight way 7 check King the 6 Knight
to c8
King c7 King takes d5 King to g8 King c6
threatening checkmate on the 8th King to
d8 Europe York is on e3 your king is on
c6 blacks King is on the eighth night is
on b2 and now you have moved that forces
the loose of the loss of piece there's
probably more than one option of
actually winning that position but the
easiest
yep rookie for king c8 is checkmate on
the it came 93 or 91 roopd foreign you
grab the knife hmm there's plenty of
ways to win this position I'm pretty
sure King b5 as well works and then just
get with the King closer to the night
and then whenever he goes to D 1 because
that's all that's going to be his only
square I think we're going to get with
the King on b3 put the rookin e2 and
then king c2 should trap the knight on
d1
so let's go let's save like this
[ __ ] I think you have to go here the
knight doesn't go anywhere
and then King c2m just wins yeah but
rookie 4 is much more elegant and just
finishes the game on the spot all right
let's take it from the beginning because
after a king before probably Bishop a4
will be a little bit more resilient what
I want you guys to to find right now is
a setup that wins the piece by force
and that just doesn't leave your
opponent absolutely any any sort of
escape try to trap that try to trap that
night King see 391 King before we shop
eh let's say or d7 Bishop oh I ate I'm
going because I want to go to h5 yeah
Bishop I ate let's say that's one one
thing about it if you're going to give
me another move after rook d2 rubgy 291
I'm going to play Bishop e8 Bishop h5
and I'm going to transfer my bishop on a
longer diagonal at least I'm going to
have more space there so you have to
stop me from doing that the King is
perfectly placed on d4 to be honest
maja King let's see here
[Music]
that's it I take
Oh actually no nights if I go king of
force sorry yeah you want to play 95
good question
94 okay I can get for night work be
careful because I might escape am i
escaping maybe I'm not escaping but I am
escaping no I'm not escaping look after
so I'm not escaping like that either
yeah that's one way I think much easier
is maybe just night 95 isn't this much
easier to have 93 95 coming with with
Chuck and that's it easy as that alright
Jonathan's first first guess first
problem is Jonathan Isaac's was a boring
end game let's let's go into much let's
go into a bit more exciting stuff I have
a very nice one for you guys this is a
nice one why to move right right right
no that makes a lot of sense the problem
is the king is also a little bit exposed
White's King and you simply don't have a
way out I think going back on the C file
is the only way otherwise
oh I'm taking the e7 pawn rook e1 if you
go on the e-file then I'm taking the
pawn and I think this is losing for you
hey cell phone I sacrifice what actually
I even have c6 in this particular case
but let's say you put your King here
yeah take go here
and then I think this position is just
losing play something like c5 maybe even
take just just take the pawn yeah
probably not the best g7 Chuck I take it
King f6 I'll take that with the check
King b1 King takes c6 a7 okapi so I I'm
Anna stew to defend against your
promotion in this position this position
and then one so let's say rook d7 I go
rook e1
or actually even rook a1 I think it's
better and when ego is u7i go rook e1
I'm okay with giving one rook
you might be able to actually or not
you're not gonna make a draw no Jack I
take
maybe yeah maybe it's a it's a draw
it's a draw it's a drop but I think we
can do better than that
I think we can try for a win here
is so II seven rookie one that's just
the beginning a 700 K 1 and now rugby
one how is black going to defend you
have to do you have to look at
differences for black as well
oh okay - yeah keep going King b3
okay - yeah then he has to go rock a
tree then it has to go here then they
have to go here
then you have to go here that's game
over yeah that's it all right
let's see another one
how about we go on mr. herbs herbs money
yeah
mr. herb SMO we have to make a draw in
this one let's try to make a draw where
95 first move okay
I have two options I have six or 96 I
have to defend that point if I lose that
pawn then it's kind of obvious is going
to be a drop so write g5 let's go with
this one Knight d6 or f6 let's try to
find for both of them again try to keep
an organized thought process
[Music]
correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's uh that's
definitely one way also night g9g six
king summer 95 and then i take the night
on a six that works as well
so f six is not good night this six we
should be thinking about once again the
first moves let's try to go along with
the variations that are most first there
is one in particular we really cannot
avoid and that is Arjun
yes Minor peaceful versus Bishop and two
nights no I don't think so
that's a good question actually but I
assume not because I'm going to be able
to exchange one of my nights for one of
your either your bishop or your night
and that should be enough no come on
guys there is there's one move that
cannot escape you it's not very
difficult
of course night of seven has to be
calculated I mean is the four is the
forced move and at least it leads to a
variation in which we can add give a new
assessment to the position yeah so night
f7 high-tech step seven night
ninety-six
now King D seven or King c8 while
actually King this seven let's look at
King D seven has all in that position
where are you going to go mmm-hmm go on
yes
why not ninety-five King c6 yeah Knight
takes a six king b7 Bishop d3 95 you
should be five not King b6 and I and I
take your night so not ninety six we
have to go for Knight g5 yeah be careful
because this is just music
loses the piece so instead of that I'm
gonna go King gay bishop g6 very good
you're threatening Knight g5 so first
move Bishop c1 exactly what to do now
now you have to be really careful very
very careful work
oh yeah that's winning yeah
ninety-eight King takes d8 Bishop takes
f7 I'm going to force you to give me the
bishop for the pawn we need to advance
my pawn all the way until the end and
then is going to be Bishop and night
versus King which I hope you guys know
how to convert again forced moves you
guys can't know for and I just have on
king of it doesn't help your cause too
much and it can easily be calculated I
just have on King f8 I put my King on g8
and I escaped I'm not I'm no longer on
that annoying pin h5 v8 if I managed to
escape from that pin my I mean
slowly-slowly I'm going to push your
pieces back and that's going to be with
Bishop d3 is the only move that you guys
should be looking at it's forced
and we should be five it's a checkmate
threat right after all so I mean it has
to be calculated of course
and that's exactly where the difference
with King the one Bishop h6 comes into
play because after Bishop d3 King the
seven we have the extra move Knight well
faith check with a bishop on h6 that
wouldn't be possible correct King Bishop
King 896 fine fine with me
so after Bishop d3 the critical line is
Knight be a we should be 597 always go
with the force moves again Knight a
faking a faith that's losing if you
exchange a knight that's losing that's
losing yeah if you exchange night that's
losing if you go Knight c5i go Knight e5
if you go 97 I go King D 896 King c8 my
king escapes
now the key of of the problem comes
mmm-hmm no Bishop I for I mean you have
to ask yourself what my threat is I have
threats as black and threatening to put
my knight on e5 and then to go king f7
if I manage to liberate my king the
position is winning No
so you midnight c5 again I go Knight e5
Knight f5 and then if you take on d7
then I take back with night my king
escape and slowly slowly I'm going to
push push the e-pawn 4c to sacrifice the
night for the for the e pawn and then
Bishop Knight versus King which is a
weak King the one Bishop h6 correct game
over
you
exactly exactly so that's the only
square with which I from which I control
both nights what do you play if you play
here I check if you move the bishop I
move the King I'm gonna go wherever I
want you know I'm gonna go you can go
with the bishop wherever you want
I'm just staying on lights worse
whenever you move one of the Knights I
check you on the other side and I go
always only to always only to yeah
simple sort of and this is it
white to move and the first thing you
have to kind of understand whenever
you're solving studies is what result
you're looking for yes Arjun that's a
good question I think it is yeah yeah
generally castling whenever you see this
type of setups in studies it's legal so
castle will be a legal move I think
you're right Arjun we are trying to draw
this position
f7 alright let's go with f7 king takes
f7
game over here
but I have a feeling f7 is correct so
we're going to leave it on the board
okay you're on the right track 93 a to
Castle King g6 we're ok 1 yeah how to
continuous black can we can we can we
improve the position can we try to pose
some problems but if you go pick up the
tool let's see how I'm going to solve my
problems
efore yeah mm-hmm whoever said that yeah
I think it has the way to go before and
after Bishop d2 before and I think
that's a blockade you cannot bring your
king and you cannot force my knight to
move away if you don't do that then I
think the position is quite easily drawn
I'm just going to bring my King King f2
etc etc correct black-white should play
it for right black should play for
otherwise if you allow me to play for as
white again is going to be a blockade so
black has to go if or night before
mm-hmm mm-hmm
Knight takes a two
Bishop g7 yes and what now
good calculation so far
I don't know I'm obviously threatening
Bishop takes b2 and rook takes a tube if
you go b3 I think I'm just moving my
rook and then you have to move your rook
and then I take on a2 and that's it yeah
rook and Bishop versus rook if you
manage to you change the last the last
pair of pawns it's a draw but if you
don't then Issa if we if we if black
manages to save a pair of points then
he's going to be winning and what I
noticed and what I love about solving
studies is that is that it definitely
increases my resilience in practical
play as well because you're always
looking for artistic way ways out out of
danger it helps a lot so if you've ever
if you're ever like training for a
specific tournament or if you're just in
training camp for for an event then I
thinking the inclusion of studies is is
extremely important in your training
routine well I mean if you're gonna
guess every single move sure you're
going to find the solution at some point
but that's what I mean by by forcing
yourself to actually try to find it from
point A to point B without guessing
because when you solve it by yourself
you're going to have to look in the book
for the solution yeah and then if you
guess then you just see the solution and
you spoil the whole exercise for
yourself yeah King g2 is the move
Bishop takes b2 what now III and it's
blocked yeah support ratio while
depending on where he goes if he tries
to go this way then we can just keep the
rook on the second rack yeah there's no
way he can invade with the King if he
tries to go this way then right now we
have to be careful of his intrusion via
d5 c4 so I think right now we can just
simply move our King yeah and there's no
way he can get out of it that's it quite
logical yeah you see the common
denominator in this in these studies is
that towards the end there was not not a
lot to calculate but rather to create a
certain defensive pattern you know and
understand it
[Music]